Si vous voulez savoir comment jouer avec un homard, nous en avons quelques-uns ici.
Et ce n'est pas une blague, nous en avons réellement.
Donc venez après la conférence et je vous montrerai comment jouer avec un homard.
Donc, en fait, j'ai commencé à travailler sur ce qu'on appelle la crevette-mante
il y a de cela quelques années parce qu'elles produisent un son.
C'est un enregistrement que j'ai fait, d'une crevette-mante
qui a été trouvée sur la côte de la Californie.
Et bien que ce soit un son absolument fascinant,
ce projet s'est avéré être très difficile.
Et pendant que j'avais du mal à comprendre comment et pourquoi la crevette-mante,
ou les stomatopodes, produisent un son, j'ai commencé à penser à leurs appendices.
Et les crevettes-mantes sont appelées crevette-mante à causes des mantes-religieuses,
qui ont elles aussi un appendice rapide pour se nourrir. Et j'ai commencé à penser,
tiens, peut-être qu'il serait intéressant, pendant que j'écoute leurs sons,
que j'essaye de comprendre comment ces animaux génèrent des coups très rapides pour se nourrir.
Et donc aujourd'hui, je vais parler du coup extrême du stomatopode,
un travail que j'ai réalisé en collaboration avec Wyatt Korff et Roy Caldwell.
Donc, les crevettes-mantes se répartissent dans deux groupes:
il y a les harponneurs et les briseurs.
Et ceci est une crevette-mante harponneuse ou stomatopode .
Et il vit dans le sable, et il attrape les choses qui passent au dessus de sa tête.
Donc, c'est un coup rapide comme cela. Et si nous ralentissons un peu,
c'est une crevette-mante -- la même espèce --
enregistrée à 1000 images par seconde,
lue à 15 images par seconde.
Et vous pouvez voir que c'est vraiment une extension spectaculaire des membres,
se projetant vers le haut pour en fait juste attraper
un bout de crevette morte que je lui ai offert.
Maintenant, l'autre genre de crevette-mante est le stomatopode briseur.
et ces gars ouvrent des escargots pour vivre.
Et alors ce gars a un escargot fermé et il lui donne un bon coup.
(Rires)
Je vais le rejouer une fois de plus.
Il le remue sur place, le sent avec son nez, et le frappe.
Et après quelques coups, l'escargot est cassé et ouvert, et il a un bon repas.
L'appendice raptorial briseur peut transpercer avec une pointe à l'extrémité,
ou il peut le frapper avec le talon.
Et aujourd'hui je vais vous parler du genre de coup briseur.
Et la première question qui m'est venue à l'esprit fut,
et bien, à quelle vitesse ce membre bouge-t-il?
Parce qu'il se déplace franchement vite dans cette vidéo.
Et je me suis immédiatement heurté à un problème.
Aucune camera à haute vitesse dans le département de biologie
à Berkeley n'était assez rapide pour capturer ce mouvement.
Nous ne pouvions simplement pas le capturer sur une vidéo.
Et cela m'a coincé pendant un bon moment.
Puis, une équipe de la BBC est venue faire une un tour dans le département de biologie,
ils cherchaient une histoire sur les nouvelles technologies dans la biologie.
Et donc nous conclu un accord.
J'ai dit,"Et bien, si vous nous louez votre caméra à haute vitesse
qui pourrait capturer ces mouvements,
vous pourrez nous filmer en train de collecter les données."
Et croyez-le ou non, ils étaient d'accord.
Donc, nous avons eu cet incroyable système vidéo. C'est une technologie très récente --
c'est sorti l'année dernière --
cela vous permet de filmer à des vitesses extrêmement élevées avec une faible luminosité.
Et la luminosité faible est un problème majeur lorsqu'on filme des animaux,
parce que si elle est trop élevée, vous les brûlez.
Ceci est une crevette-mante. Il y a les yeux en haut là,
et il y a cet appendice raptorial, et il y a le talon.
Et cette chose va tourner et frapper l'escargot.
Et l'escargot est attaché à un bâtonnet,
ainsi, placer le coup est plus facile. Et -- ouai.
(Rires)
J'espère qu'il n'y a pas de défenseurs des droits de l'escargot dans la salle.
Alors ceci a été filmé à 5000 images par seconde,
et je la lis à 15. Et c'est donc ralenti 333 fois.
Et comme vous pouvez le voir, c'est encore bigrement rapide
en étant ralenti 333 fois. C'est un mouvement incroyablement puissant
Tout le membre s'étend vers l'extérieur. Le corps se fléchit en arrière --
un mouvement spectaculaire.
Et ce que nous avons fait, c'est de jeter un coup d'œil à ces vidéos,
et nous avons mesuré à quelle vitesse le membre bougeait
pour revenir à notre question d'origine.
Et ce fut notre première surprise.
Donc nous avons calculé que les membres bougeaient
à une vitesse de pointe allant de 10 mètres par seconde
jusqu'à un maximum de 23 mètres par seconde.
Et pour ceux qui préfèrent les kilomètres par heure,
cela fait plus de 72 kilomètres par heure dans l'eau. Et c'est vraiment très rapide.
En fait, c'est tellement rapide que nous avons pu mettre une information supplémentaire
dans la catégorie des mouvements extrêmes des animaux.
Et la crevette-mante est officiellement l'animal possédant le mouvement pour se nourrir mesuré le plus rapide
de n'importe quel règne animal. Voilà notre première surprise.
(applaudissements)
C'était vraiment super et très inattendu.
Alors, vous devez peut-être vous demander, comment font-ils ça?
En fait, ce travail a été fait dans les années 60.
par un célèbre biologiste du nom de Malcom Burrows.
Et il a démontré que la crevette-mante utilise
ce qu'on appelle un mécanisme de capture, ou mécanisme à clic.
Et il est essentiellement composé d'un grand muscle
qui met un long moment à se contracter,
et d'un loquet qui empêche tout mouvement.
Donc le muscle se contracte, et rien ne se passe.
Et une fois que le muscle est complètement contracté, tout est mis en réserve --
le loquet est propulsé vers le haut, et vous avez le mouvement.
Et c'est ce qu'on appelle simplement un système d'amplification de puissance.
Le muscle met un long moment pour se contracter,
et le membre se déploie dans un moment très court.
Et alors j'ai pensé que c'était en quelque sorte la fin de l'histoire.
Voilà comment les crevettes-mantes réalisent ces coups très rapides.
Mais ensuite j'ai fait une excursion au Musée National d'Histoire Naturelle.
Et si certains d'entre vous en ont la possibilité,
dans les coulisses du Musée National d'Histoire Naturelle
il y a l'une des meilleures collections au monde de crevettes-mantes conservées. Et ce que --
(Rires)
c'est une affaire sérieuse pour moi.
Donc, voilà -- ce que j'ai vu, sur chaque membre d'une crevette-mante,
qu'elle soit de type harponneur ou briseur,
c'est une belle structure en forme de selle
juste sur la surface supérieure du membre. Et vous pouvez le voir ici.
Cela ressemble à une selle que vous mettriez sur un cheval.
C'est une structure magnifique.
Et elle est entourée de secteurs membraneux. Et ces secteurs membraneux
m'ont fait pensé que c'est peut être une sorte de structure dynamique et flexible.
Et cette sorte de structure m'a laissé perplexe pendant un moment.
Puis, ensuite nous avons fait des séries de calcul, et ce que nous avons pu démontrer
c'est que les crevettes-mantes doivent avoir un ressort.
Il doit y avoir un genre de mécanisme de rechargement à ressort
pour générer la quantité de force que nous observons,
ainsi que la vitesse que nous observons, et la production du système.
Donc nous nous sommes dit, OK, c'est surement un ressort --
la selle pourrait très bien être un ressort.
Et nous nous sommes repenchés sur ces vidéos à haute vitesse,
et nous avons pu visualiser la selle se compresser et s'étendre.
Et je vais le repasser encore une fois.
Puis si vous regardez bien dans la vidéo --
c'est assez difficile de le voir -- c'est surligné en jaune.
La selle est surlignée en jaune. Vous pouvez en fait la voir
en extension pendant la course du coup, et à vrai dire en hyper-extension.
Donc, nous avions une preuve très solide qui montrait
que cette structure en forme de selle se compresse et s'étend,
et agit vraiment, comme un ressort.
La structure en forme de selle est aussi connue pour sa surface paraboloïde hyperbolique,
ou une surface anticlastique.
Et elle est très bien connue des ingénieurs et architectes,
parce que c'est une surface très dure, résistant à la compression.
Elle est faite de courbes en deux directions,
une courbe incurvée vers le haut et une courbe transversale opposée, incurvée vers le bas
donc n'importe quelle sorte de perturbation répand les forces
sur toute la surface de ce genre de forme.
Donc c'est très bien connu des ingénieurs, mais pas aussi bien des biologistes.
C'est aussi connu d'un bon nombre de personnes qui créent des bijoux,
parce que cela requiert très peu de matière
pour fabriquer ce genre de surface, et c'est très solide.
Donc si vous voulez construire une structure mince en or,
c'est très bien d'avoir une forme solide.
Maintenant, c'est également connu des architectes. L'un des architectes les plus célèbres ,
est Eduardo Catalano, qui a rendu cette structure populaire.
Et ce qui est montré ici, c'est un toit en forme de selle qu'il a construit
qui fait 26,7 mètres d'envergure.
Il fait 6,35 cm d'épaisseur, et est supporté en deux points.
Et l'une des raisons pour laquelle il a conçu ces toits de cette façon c'est --
qu'il trouvait fascinant de pouvoir construire une structure si solide
à partir de si peu de matière et qui puisse être supportée par si peu de points.
Et tout ceci fait parti du même principe qui s'applique
au ressort en forme de selle chez le stomatopode.
Dans les systèmes biologiques il est important de ne pas avoir besoin
de matériau supplémentaire pour le construire.
Donc, ce sont des parallèles très intéressants entre le monde biologique
et le monde de l'ingénierie. Et curieusement, il s'avère --
que la selle du stomatopode est la première
description d'un ressort paraboloïde hyperbolique et biologique.
C'est un peu long, mais c'est plutôt intéressant.
Puis la question suivante, et la dernière, était, quelle est la force
que produit une crevette-mante si elle est capable de briser des escargots?
Et j'ai donc câblé ce qu'on appelle un capteur de force.
Un capteur de force mesure les forces et c'est en vérité
un capteur piezoélectrique qui a un petit cristal à l'intérieur.
Et quand le cristal est pressé, les propriétés électriques changent
proportionnellement aux forces exercées sur ce dernier.
Donc ces animaux sont merveilleusement agressifs,
et sont tout le temps très affamés. Et donc, tout ce que j'avais à faire
était de mettre un peu de pâte de crevette sur la façade du capteur de force,
et ils le frapperaient.
Et donc ceci est juste une vidéo ordinaire de l'animal
frappant un bon nombre de fois le capteur de force.
Et nous avons pu avoir à la sortie quelques mesures de force.
Et encore une fois, ce fut une surprise pour nous.
J'ai acheté un capteur de force de 450 Newtons, pensant,
qu'aucun animal de cette taille ne pourrait produire plus de 450 Newtons.
Et comme vous le savez, ils ont immédiatement dépassé la capacité du capteur.
Donc ici vous pouvez voir quelques vieilles données
que j'ai trouvées sur le plus petit animal du laboratoire,
et nous pouvions mesurer des forces bien supérieures à 450 Newtons
générées par un animal de cette taille.
Et en fait, la semaine dernière j'ai pris un capteur de force de 1330 Newtons
en état de marche, et nous avons mesuré des forces générées par ces animaux
dépassant 890 Newtons.
Et encore une fois, je pense que ça sera un record mondial.
Je dois faire un peu de recherche pour le vérifier
mais je pense que ça sera la plus grande quantité de force produite
par un animal ramené à l'unité de masse. Donc ce sont des forces incroyables.
Et encore une fois, cela nous ramène à l'importance de ce ressort
dans le stockage et la libération de tant d'énergie dans ce système.
Mais ce n'est pas la fin de l'histoire.
Maintenant, ces choses -- je les fais apparaître facilement, mais c'est en vérité beaucoup de travail.
Et j'ai eu toutes ces mesures de force,
et puis je suis allé voir la production de force du système.
Et c'est vraiment très simple -- le temps est sur l'axe des X
et la force sur l'axe des Y. Et vous pouvez voir deux pics.
Et cela m'a rendu vraiment perplexe.
Le premier pic, est évidemment le coup du membre sur le capteur de force.
Mais il y a un second grand pic une demie milliseconde plus tard,
et je ne savais pas ce que c'était.
Donc maintenant, vous pourriez supposer un second pic pour d'autres raisons,
mais pas une demie milliseconde plus tard.
Je reviens encore sur ces vidéos à haute vitesse,
il y a un bon indice de ce qui pourrait se passer.
Voici la même orientation que nous avons vu plus tôt.
Ici nous avons l'appendice raptorial -- là le talon,
et il va tourner et frapper le capteur de force.
Et ce que je voudrais que vous fassiez dans cette capture, c'est de garder vos yeux sur
la surface du capteur de force, quand le membre s'y déploie.
Et j'espère que vous êtes capable de voir un flash de lumière.
Audience: Ouah.
Sheila Patek: Et si nous prenons seulement une image, ce que vous pouvez voir
au bout de la flèche jaune est une bulle de vapeur.
Et c'est la cavitation.
Et la cavitation est un puissant phénomène hydrodynamique
qui se produit lorsque vous avez des zones d'eau
qui bougent à différentes vitesses extrêmes.
Et lorsque cela arrive, cela peut créer des zones de très basse pression
ce qui aboutit littéralement à une vaporisation de l'eau.
Et lorsque cette bulle de vapeur éclate, elle émet du son, de la lumière et de la chaleur
et c'est un processus très destructif.
Et donc là c'est sur le stomatopode. Et encore une fois, c'est une situation
où les ingénieurs sont très familiers avec ce phénomène,
parce que cela détruit les hélices de bateau.
Des personnes ont travaillé pendant des années pour essayer et concevoir
une hélice de bateau tournant à haute vitesse qui ne crée pas de cavitation
et use littéralement le métal et fait des trous dedans.
comme on peut le voir sur ces photos.
Donc c'est une force puissante dans les systèmes hydrauliques, et l'étape d'après
je vais vous montrer la crevette-mante approchant un escargot.
Cela a été pris à 20 mille images par seconde, et
tout le mérite en revient au caméraman de la BBC, Tim Green, pour l'avoir filmé,
parce que je n'aurais pas pu le faire même dans un million d'années.
L'un des avantages de travailler avec un caméraman professionnel.
Vous pouvez le voir entrer en collision, et un flash incroyable de lumière
et toute la cavitation se propagent sur toute la surface de l'escargot.
Donc c'est vraiment une image impressionnante,
extrêmement ralentie, à des vitesses extrêmement lentes.
Et encore une fois, nous pouvons le voir légèrement différemment d'ici,
avec la formation de la bulle et son éclatement entre ces deux surfaces.
En fait, vous avez peut-être vu une cavitation remontant le bord du membre.
Donc, pour expliquer le dilemme concernant ces deux pics de force:
je pense que cela se passe ainsi, le premier impact est en fait
le coup porté sur le capteur de force par le membre, et le second impact est
l'éclatement de la bulle de cavitation.
Et ces animaux pourraient très bien utiliser
non seulement la force et l'énergie stockée par leur ressort spécialisé,
mais aussi les propriétés extrêmes de la dynamique des fluides. Et ils utilisent peut-être
la dynamique des fluides comme une seconde force pour casser l'escargot.
Donc c'est un double coup dur fascinant, pour ainsi dire, de la part de ces animaux.
Donc, une question qu'on me pose souvent après ce discours --
j'y ai pensé et je voudrais y répondre maintenant -- c'est, qu'arrive-t-il à l'animal?
Parce que manifestement, si il brise des escargots,
le pauvre membre doit se désintégrer. Et c'est le cas.
Ceci est la surface d'impact du talon sur ces deux images,
et il sont usés. En fait, je les ai déjà vus user
leur talon entièrement jusqu'à la chair.
Mais l'un des avantages d'être un arthropode
c'est qu'il doit muer. Et toutes les trois semaines environ,
ces animaux muent, et fabriquent un nouveau membre et il n'y a aucun problème.
Une solution très très pratique pour ce problème particulier.
Donc, je voudrais finir sur une note plutôt dingue.
(Rires)
Peut-être que tout ceci est dingue pour des gens comme vous, je ne sais pas.
Donc, le ressort -- le ressort en forme de selle --
est en fait bien connu par les biologistes depuis longtemps,
pas comme un ressort mais comme un signal visuel.
Et il y a un point coloré spectaculaire
au centre de la selle de beaucoup d'espèces de stomatopode.
Et c'est tout à fait intéressant, de trouver les origines évolutives
des signaux visuels sur ce qui est vraiment, chez toutes les espèces, leurs ressorts.
Et je pense qu'une explications possible pour cela pourrait être
de revenir au phénomène de mue.
Donc ces animaux entre dans une période de mue quand ils sont
incapables de frapper -- leurs corps deviennent très mous.
Et ils sont littéralement incapables de frapper sinon ils s'auto-détruisent.
Ceci est vrai. Et ce qu'ils font, pendant toute la période
pendant laquelle ils ne peuvent frapper, ils deviennent très odieux et affreux,
et ils frappent tout ce qu'ils voient, peu importe quoi ou qui.
Et ensuite ils arrivent au point où ils ne peuvent plus du tout frapper,
ils envoient seulement des signaux. Ils agitent leurs pattes.
Et c'est l'un des exemples classiques de bluff dans le comportement animal.
C'est un fait très bien établi que ces animaux
peuvent bluffer. Ils ne peuvent en vérité pas frapper, mais ils font semblant.
Et je suis très curieuse de savoir si ces points colorés
situés au centre des selles communiquent quelques informations
sur leur capacité à frapper, ou leur force de frappe,
ou quelque chose sur la période du cycle de mue.
Donc c'est un fait étrange et intéressant de trouver une structure visuelle
juste au milieu de leur ressort.
Donc pour conclure, je suis surtout reconnaissante à mes deux collaborateurs,
Wyatt Korff et Roy Caldwell, qui ont étroitement travaillé avec moi sur ce projet.
Et aussi le Miller Institute for Basic Research in Science,
qui m'a donné trois années de financement pour faire de la science tout le temps ,
et pour cela je leurs suis très reconnaissante. Merci beaucoup.
(Applaudissements)